Speaker 1: Well, this is just unbelievable,
except, of course, it's not Mark Meadows,
who served as Donald Trump's chief of staff up
until the end of Donald Trump's presidential term,
has now been accused of burning official
documents in his office. Yes, a fire in his
office. It is stunning what we continue to learn
about what took place. Politico reports Meadows
burned papers after meeting with Scott Perry.
January 6th panel was told. Then White House
Chief of Staff Mark Meadows burned papers in his
office after meeting with a House Republican who
was working to challenge the 2020 election.
According to testimony that the January six
committee heard from Cassidy Hutchinson, who
worked under Meadows when he was Trump's chief
of staff. The Meadows Perry meeting came in
the weeks after Election Day as Trump and his
allies searched for ways to reverse the election
results. It's unclear whether Hutchinson told the
committee which specific papers were burnt and
if federal records laws required the materials
preservation. Meadows Destruction of Papers
is a key focus for the select committee and
the person familiar with the testimony said.
Investigators pressed Hutchinson for details
about the issue for more than 90 minutes.
For more than 90 minutes. Another report
from the Hill. Former Trump White House aide
Cassidy Hutchinson indicated Mark Meadows
burned documents in his fireplace roughly a dozen
times in the final weeks of the administration.
Hutchinson became a star witness in the panel's
public hearings, told the committee on May
17th she saw Meadows burn documents once they
turned his office fireplace. Once they turned,
I guess it's supposed to say turned his fireplace
on in December of 2020. The Presidential Records
Act only asks that you keep the original copy
of a document. So, yes, Hutchinson asked,
said when asked if she saw Meadows use the
fireplace to burn documents, however. I don't
know if they were the first or original copies
of anything. It's entirely possible he had put
things in his fireplace he would have put into a
burn bag that were duplicates or that were. There
was an electronic copy of, I want to say once
or twice a week. I can't recall. I can recall
specific times. He did it maybe a dozen, maybe
just over a dozen. But this was over a period
December through mid-January, which is when
we started lighting the fireplace. Think of
what was going on at this White House. Trump's
flushing documents down the toilet. Meadows is
burning documents in a fireplace. Totally normal
presidential office stuff. As a general rule,
functioning democracies don't burn official
documents in a fireplace. Functioning democracies
don't flush official documents down the toilet.
And functioning democracies don't elect mob boss
types to run countries. Now, we have seen mob
boss types run a number of different countries,
and we know it doesn't typically go particularly
well. So the critical question here, of course,
is were these originals that were supposed to be
maintained as part of the Presidential Records
Act? Were these duplicates of some kind? Are there
electronic records? We just don't know at this
time. What we do know is if their originals under
federal law, it is a crime to destroy, alter,
mutilate, conceal, cover up, falsify or make a
false entry in any record document or tangible
object with the intent to impede, obstruct or
influence a federal investigation or any matter
within the jurisdiction of any department or
agency of the United States. That's a very
long rule or a very long law. What it means is
any alteration or destruction of a document.
With the intent of getting in the way or
preventing a future investigation. Making
a future investigation difficult is a crime. The
offense is punishable by a fine and imprisonment
and or imprisonment up to 20 years. In addition
to that, the federal records, laws and regulations
require that federal agencies properly create,
manage and preserve records, including those
related to the White House. NARA The National
Archives and Records Administration, an often
mentioned organization in the context of the Trump
administration, oversees all of that and can take
disciplinary action against federal employees.
Do I expect Meadows to go down for this?
I really don't. This is more about the habitual.
Speaker 3: Ease.
Speaker 1: With which these people regularly
violated sometimes the law. Sometimes convention
and often protocol. And we're really going to get
a test of whether our legal system and rules and
regulations and checks and balances are actually
strong enough to create or generate a result in
consequences for the so many different people that
participated in the wrongdoing. We'll find out.